China says it will revoke the
credentials of Americans at three US
newspapers in response to new US
restrictions on Chinese media the
foreign ministry wants journalists
working for the New York Times Wall
Street Journal and The Washington Post
whose credentials are due to expire
before the end of 2020 to hand back
their press cards within ten days that
move comes after the Trump
administration designated five Chinese
media outlets as foreign missions and
restricted the number of Chinese who
could work for them late today the Trump
administration called the decision yet
another step toward depriving the
Chinese people and the world of access
to true information about China